extension officers from across the
Caribbean region have gathered for a
week-long comprehensive farmer field
School facilitator training organized by
the Ministry of Agriculture Fisheries
food security and rural development in
collaboration with the ACP Me 3 project
the training aims to enhance their
facilitation skills and provide them
with updated knowledge and tools for
delivering effective farmer fi school
extension programs throughout the
training extension officers will explore
various topics related to the farmer fi
School
implementation including the purpose and
potential impact of farma field schools
strategies for planning and Community
engagement and familiarization with the
recently updated farmer field School
manual the objective as stated by the
ACP maa's three regional project
coordinator ter yard is to enable
extension officers to better engage with
Farmers share information and provide
guidance on the responsible use of
pesticides the FAO has supported the
update of St Lu's farmer field School
manual um which dated back to I believe
2006 Mr Alexis so you now have a uh new
farmer field School manual which we're
in the process of developing to publish
as an official FAO publication so we're
very pleased about that and as well
following on from this training we will
be supporting the extension services
unit in the delivery of farmer field
schools focused on reducing the use of
Highly H hazardous pesticides so before
the end of the year hopefully some of
you who participate in this training
today will actually be involved in the
delivery of farmer field schools in your
respective region Chief extension
officer Eloy Alexis expressed enthusiasm
about the acquired skills and resources
he emphasizes the importance of the
training in enhancing the ability of the
extension officers to to deliver
impactful farmer field school programs
and support farmers in adopting
sustainable agricultural practices this
movement has spread globally as an
effective teaching um
methodology the concept Embraces the
preservation of agroecological system to
guarantee sustainability of
production As sectoral
Leaders we must be um equipped with the
requisite knowled
which will help cushion the myriads of
challenges faced by our farming sector
which has the potential to weaken our
food security status aggravate onsets of
non-communicable diseases and the
destruction of the environment the
collaborative efforts of the Ministry of
Agriculture and the ACP maas3 project in
organizing the farmer field School
facilitator training highlights their
commitment to promoting sustainable
agriculture and food Security in the
Caribbean
with improved facilitation skills and
the updated manual extension officers
will be equipped to lead farmer field
schools Empower farmers and contribute
to the Agricultural sector's Development
from the communications unit of the
Ministry of Agriculture I am Ania antoan
reporting